was a healthy
and active nine-year-old so why did she
become so unwell
and later die from a severe asthma
attack
it's a question her mom rosamund who
arrived at southwark
coroner's court with her two children
has spent the last seven years
trying to get answered i knew that i
would get to the bottom of it
i didn't imagine this though this isn't
what i imagined how it's panned out
i thought i would get an answer maybe i
thought it would be really simple
i didn't realize it was going to be this
complicated in the three years before
ella died in 2013
she was taken to hospital on nearly 30
occasions with breathing difficulties
she also suffered multiple seizures
at an inquest today a coroner ruled that
air pollution
did contribute to her death for her
is finally getting justice i think
myself and her consultants we had an
issue with the word
respiratory failure respiratory failure
could be a hundred-year-old
sits down to watch tv and suddenly dies
and they'll put
on their death certificate respiratory
failure i didn't think respiratory
failure
told us what really happened to her you
don't get a child
suddenly become that ill out of the blue
from nowhere
and then they die there has to be a
reason the question is
can you find that reason sometimes guess
what in life you can't always
i knew there was something but i didn't
know what
ella's home was 25 meters from the south
circular
in southeast london a major ring road
notorious for pollution
and often clogged with heavy traffic the
coroner said
dangerous levels of nitrogen dioxide
near to where she lived
exceeded world health organization and
eu guidelines
and her untimely death is due to the
toxic air she breathed
this is the day ella's family have spent
the last seven years fighting for
the coroner here has made legal history
by ruling for the first time ever
that air pollution is what caused the
school girl's death
and for campaigners today's verdict sets
the precedent for future cases
this is a once in a generation legal
result
it has massive ramifications across all
aspects of of all of our
lives i think we're going to see action
to reduce
vehicle emissions but not just those
because what this case has highlighted
is air pollution from other sources such
as construction
agriculture many different things i
think this is a
very special moment and rosamund has
done a wonderful thing
for many many millions of people
for ella's mom it was too late to save
her daughter
but she hopes if air pollution is
treated with the urgency that it should
be
then more lives can be saved no phillips
sky news in south london